[Music]
okay let's talk Google Cloud
workstations uh what is it how it helps
developers and it folks and examples of
how you might use it
so first off what is it uh workstations
are an on-demand consistent Cloud
development environment with a focus on
security and faster Dev onboarding
but that could be a lot of things so
specifically what is it it is a web
application hosted in the cloud console
to create and manage container images
which are then used as templates to
create development environments that run
on a dedicated VM for each developer
so you've got a template kick that off
start a VM and then that's the dev
environment for for each of the
developers and they can access that over
SSH TCP ports or https uh proxy
connections that are authenticated by
the regular Google login to the project
and I think of this as kind of
um you know as we've been moving
applications from customized VMS to
ephemeral containers this is a similar
thing for development environments
you're trying to make them more
consistent and you know available on
demand and turn them off when you're not
using them and if you've used the cloud
shell which is the kind of console at
the at the bottom uh the command line
console at the bottom of the Google
Cloud Web console
um this product is a high powered
customizable version of that technology
and you know while the uh the core VM is
ephemeral the home directory is saved
between uses so developers can start and
stop the workstations as needed and you
know customize them and add their own
tooling and configuration to the home
directory and go from there so this is a
product that you use directly most
Google cloud services are building
blocks to assemble together to build
your own application workstations is
more like bigquery or Cloud logging it's
an application that you use directly and
you create these templates and kind of
go from there
so so what uh you know why how does this
help people uh get their jobs done save
time that sort of thing so I think the
at a high level you know this on-demand
environment is accessible anywhere that
either your developers have web access
from any machine with a browser
um and this is you know really powerful
um and it gives you
uh your op all of your users are kind of
operating in the cloud so all of us uh
developers which is really nice
um and you know we provide some managed
base images
um and Docker images that have a bunch
of things installed including support
for multiple Ides such as
um vs code and IntelliJ pycharm things
like that
um and since it's a container image you
can add your own layers on top of that
it's fully customizable you could add
different extensions libraries Ides
um you know whatever you need for your
organization or your local team
um and
since it is you know this kind of
container base
um it makes for a consistent environment
for all the developers on a given
project and I I love this because I
think it really helps with the you know
Common scenario and software where
you're troubleshooting something and
you're like I don't know it works on my
machine and you know this really changes
that and uh gets us you know in a
consistent place
um and I think also it creates for you
know faster onboarding uh for new folks
joining a team
and in addition to that you know we get
some uh some nice security properties
that help us make for more secure
development environments um this is
running on a VM and so you get all the
same kind of access that you would from
a regular VM you can uh connect to vpcs
or limit it to only certain vpcs uh you
have VPC search controls you can set
organizational policies for the project
itself use security tools and the like
and
the next thing is is actually the
biggest thing from my perspective
um you are now you know running your
development environment you're testing
and running in in the cloud
um on a VM and I've you know often
struggled to try to recreate
um the you know a local environment that
truly matches Cloud I think it's really
hard maybe impossible to do and so this
this gets us you know so that the code
we're running and testing and building
you know has the same kind of
performance characteristics that um same
authentication kind of uh setup that
we'll be using in a test and production
environment which just dramatically
reduces the amount of kind of fiddling
and troubleshooting you end up doing
later
um which I really like and I've been
doing it for a long time uh just over
SSH but then you don't get a full IDE
which brings me to examples
um so let me give a few examples of how
you might use this um one is related to
this last Point
um modern Ides
um can either you know run fully remote
over kind of a web interface or run in
kind of a split mode where there's an
engine that runs remotely and a local
GUI and when you run it that way with
workstations you've got the engine so
the code and the actual execution of
your code is happening in the cloud but
you're GUI and everything there is local
so it feels very fast and fluid and I
think of this as kind of Best of Both
Worlds
um it really makes things a lot more
efficient
um and in addition to that you know if
you've got tools that are purely
web-based they run great in this mode so
things like Jupiter notebooks uh are a
common example
um and they're just really handy for a
lot of uses so those run great over web
and then you also have command line
access via SSH so any of the console
tools you want to use you can go ahead
and use them
and then since this is all Container
based you know your skills for managing
containers and you know um
build pipelines and maybe policies or or
Tools around how that works in the
organization you can apply that to
development environments as well
and that's just really handy one
um works well in large organizations and
you can do things like
um install and even run tools that are
you know kind of useful for every one of
your developers if you're doing
kubernetes development for example you
could have a configured mini Cube set up
and running on a local port for each of
your developers just out of the box and
ready to go
and since this is a VM running on a VPC
um you know any other kind of devops or
a developer tooling you would like to
use such as gitlab or team City you can
install those in the same project and
have all the workstations talk to them
and you know limit access to them
and you know maybe this gave you some
ideas for how you might be able to use
it
um hope so please take a look at the
docs for them around to other teammates
and give it a try so the docs are at
cloud.google.com workstations Docs
and thanks for watching take care
[Music]